now before we begin i want to summarize
what has been a blockbuster week
one where we've learned a great deal
about how our country
really works now this week we've
established the following facts
fact one last night we heard a former
u.s secretary of state
who also was head of the cia tell us
that when the trump administration
tried to learn the truth about the
origins of kovitt
it faced opposition from its own career
staff
we overcame lots of internal bureaucracy
and lots of internal debate
from nih folks who are trying to
suppress what we do in the state
department as well
we worked diligently to get the
intelligence community to classify more
but there were
folks all over the community who just
didn't want to talk about this they
didn't want the world to know that the
chinese communist party was in the
process of covering
what turns out might have been several
million losses of life well he didn't
want to answer that
because they'll let other people decide
about motives fact two
this week we saw emails from dr fauci
showing that he was warned about the
possibility
that this virus leaked from a ccp
controlled lab
but rather than trying to get to the
truth about what had happened
he provided political cover for the ccp
while at the same time maintaining close
relations with his colleagues in china
and last night secretary pompeo let him
have it
he employs good faith for the chinese
communist party laura
here we are on the 32nd anniversary of
tiananmen square where we saw the
brutality of this regime a regime that
doesn't care about human life
for doctor factorygirl and think for a
moment that the chinese communist party
cared that there were
people in wuhan that were dying it's
just naive beyond all possible
imagination
fact number three we know beyond any
doubt that the wuhan lab
the same lab where this virus may have
been developed
was funded in part by your tax money
now that lab was conducting experiments
to make diseases more pathogenic
and again we were helping to pay for it
together these facts show that our
government
paid for with our money
is apparently more concerned about
helping the ccp
than it is about protecting our own
national interest this is
absolutely intolerable let us be very
clear
we know the ccp is an evil dictatorship
that wants to destroy freedom
everywhere on earth including the u.s it
murders and imprisons innocent people
every day it's crushed freedom in hong
kong it's committing genocide against
the uyghurs
and it has enormous support from
high-ranking
u.s officials nonetheless
we've warned you already that many of
our elites including
in our media big tech companies
hollywood
top university celebrities have acted as
the ccp's allies
and now we know that the ccp's power
reaches into our own government
now i know our country is disagreements
and that's fine but
can we not come together to ensure that
our government is free
from the taint of ccp influence
can any american honestly say that it's
good for our top officials
to care more about protecting the
reputations of their friends in china
than about telling the truth to the
american people
now going forward every member of
congress i don't care what political
party you represent
must be vigilant to ensure that never
again does an american secretary of
state have to wonder
about whether his own people are
interested in telling the truth
about china now this won't be an easy
task
but after this week we have no choice
but to take it on